dad  oh my darling happy birthday daddy you  know my friend Amanda yep her cousin  who's asked us to spend vacation with  them in Paris I really really want to go  hi Daddy  you were supposed to call me when you  land got Amanda  alright this to me go to the next  bedroom under the bed tell me when  you're there thank you now the next part  is very important they're going to take  you I don't know who you are I don't  know what you want if you're looking for  ransom I can tell you I don't have money  but what I do have are a very particular  set of skills skills I've acquired a  professional skills to make me a  nightmare for people like you  if you let my daughter go now  you have a 96 out there never finding  but if you're done I will look for you I  will find you  good luck what do you see my son was  taken  my son was taken away from me